ciao ragazzi volete anche voi smette di
far pagare in inglese siete stanchi però
delle vostre professoresse naziste che
appena sbagliate sono prontamente più di
due in pagella avete bisogno di un punto
amichevole che qualche modo vi facciate
dire che si sente delle merde ma che
comunque delle merde nascono i fiori
eccomi qui oggi quello che vorrei fare
un piccolo esperimento per capire se
effettivamente possiamo migliorare o no
questa lingua che sicuramente più utile
dell'italiano parlando solamente in
pochissime zone dell'italia in maniera
decente nel comparto ora prima di
partire tre semplici regole prima regola
non struma telani quando si parla di
inglese c'è chi è un professorone e c'è
chi invece non vivo al sugo io non so a
chi mi sto riferendo spero semplicemente
questa roba possa essere utile per
migliorare il proprio livello seconda
regola questo qui è un posto di amicizia
va bene sbagliare va bene tutto anche io
se farà degli strafalcioni va benissimo
la cosa brutta quando si parla inglese
che un sacco di persone hanno l'ansia a
provarci a a mettersi in gioco perché
perché hanno paura delle critiche hanno
paura di sbagliare sbagliare
fa bene prima di imparare a camminare
non sbattiamo la testa un sacco di volte
ma quando sono piccoli non ce ne
preoccupiamo continuano a farlo terza
regola provateci anche a costo di
sembrare stupidi ci sono persone che
hanno vergogna a parlare inglese per
paura di quello che gli altri italiani
potrebbero dire di loro inglese lo
parlerai con gli stranieri e quindi
automaticamente non deve interessare
quello che gli italiani dicono molto
meglio essere ridicolizzati dagli
italiani con i quali non parlerà inglese
che con gli inglesi con i quali lo
parlerà al senso questa frase va detto
lo scopo di questo video non è quello di
renderli perfetti quindi prendiamo tutti
quanti un bel respiro ma di renderlo un
pochino più comprensibili ora servono 2
con sé per sé comprensibili pronuncia
intonazione oggi parleremo un pochino di
pronuncia e importante secondo me essere
comprensibili anche perché esistono un
sacco di persone a che fingono di non
capire ha detto ciò
partiamo proprio dalle basi la prima
roba che veramente fa male alla
pronuncia el'acca ho capito che di
italiano io non è io ho in inglese
se c'è lacca il più delle volte dovete
dirlo e per dirla dovete evitare di
avere
due minuti prima perché è proprio se
volete imparare a dire ben la cappa di
20 piani di scale alla fine la saprete
benissimo fantoccio poi ti odio e molto
meglio di high iq che è che ho mangiato
molto probabilmente per versione di
questa frase una persona perché lo
dovrebbero esserci importantissimo non
serve per forza che voi di chat e poi ma
va bene anche ai tg
oppure a un play e angri quando sei in
grease e cazzuto nero quando sei in due
maniere sti quello di prima un'altra
parola ancora è o per gli americani che
operano su dire che senza l'acca
diventerebbe oppure è e poi pettinare i
capelli non puoi pettinare l'aria che
perché aveva un passatempo opinabile
un'altra cosa importante però è che
esistono 4h che io conosco che non
vengono pronunciate sono le uniche
quattro volte nelle varie lacca ve la
potete dimenticare che sono ora ha
infatti in inglese un hotel a con 12 1
radici en us onesto o un altra cosa
importante erede
e poi c'è un onore la camera potete
dimenticare le altre volte la cava
trattata la consonante
tosse il resto scale a piedi
no a censure poi non ti sta chiedendo di
fare un mutuo ti sto chiedendo le mette
nacca poi altro sono importantissimo il
th ragazzi arca è veramente ragazzata in
realtà se ci pensione da fare perché la
prova oggi bozza ma perché devo farmi
pare non essere un abile a questa cosa
fare cosa
lavoriamo è incredibile sarà se tutte le
frasi tipo frank therapy fans grazie a
tirri ha quindi anche di banti non è
così non è the big bang theory al
massimo per tiro il nazismo seconda
regola
la cosa che però frega del th e che
esiste un secondo suono colti hpa più
dolce se uno è tra l'altro è stessa
posizione ma ed è quello che così per
l'articolo da saint denis
sì ma sapeva lingua e mezzo cioè non
stata nessun'altra martina ci metta
numeri noi e non ha senso sono assurdo
sassoni fifa mia famiglia di famiglia
brucia del culo anche quello famiglia e
alla gente la lingua figura del
dinamismo e anche l'inglese non pensate
ad essere facilissimo andando avanti
abbiamo la s che importantissimi ma la s
inglese è molto più sibilante perché è
sempre
quindi se sei lento non sai mai ma sarai
se te lo dico in italiano e come dire lo
so che prolunghino e come semplici fare
fi prova esatto la era giustissima nezia
speak to una cosa importante che la s
cambia solamente in un caso se tu stai
vicino a qualcuno tu sei ma se ti dico
di chiudere la porta si trasforma da
lei sa perché un'altra cosa
l'ice e il riso prize e sole per sorge
price rice
se un verbo deve diventare per cui tutte
le parole che se le scrive teen
americano alla fine anno una z nei verbi
o se scrivete in inglese hanno un essa
alla fine non hanno la mano la prima il
rais
questa con un infarinatura se non si
deve andare troppo nello specifico fanno
solamente un video sulla ss con rottura
dico io passiamo adesso alla w ora la w
che in realtà in inglese è doppia non
viene mai pronunciata come quindi è
sempre boccuccia uomo è una cazzata lo
so we will we will smith 9 with c'è
intenso con noi siamo veri entriamo al
famoso è fiacca una cosa importante sono
lati e là di tutte e due non c'entrano
niente con l'italiano lati non è ma è
una pistola che senza pensa bravo una
pistola senza la cannuccia chi con
larghi che non et similia non so se
abbiamo sentito quelle persone che hanno
un difetto di pronuncia che io trovo
adorabile che
l'ati quelli che parlano mattinate un
dado presente che quello di così
tenetela eccole di quella più o meno la
l è fondamentale in inglese a due
varianti in inglese una che è molto più
simili al italiano quindi il long life
un'altra che invece subentra quando l st
verso la fine è come se tu cerca siti di
legame improvvisamente venissi strozzato
da un pure hunter velino il veleno il
veleno per cusco il veleno scelto
appositamente per uccidere cusco cusco
il suo veleno quello che si perda lei no
invece di dire alto sul giudici e così
via se la lingua in team e il numero in
prima fila le teneva incollati ci
provano i meno c'è non è che dico imei
dico i neo è un ciao ciao non è l a
dentro
l'unico caso in cui la l stronzata si
trasformerà nella normale e quando hai
una frase subito dopo che inizia per
vocale phone che vuol dire cadere folla
si trasforma in si fosse di cui successo
perché dopo aggiunge roba capito se tu
dici più alto tu dici con esso si è
capito un po questo scalino
quindi se in italia non volete proprio
essere super fighi magari invece di
folla detection l in tutti i modà leahy
mood food sul no ai bordi l ciao
ma la n scompare anche in altri casi
come le case di walk talk talk diventa
look book e americani pure fare la
stessa cosa solamente che è la loro
vocali diversa ricevevo gup non hanno
non avete capito cosa intendo queste
sono regole che anche gli americani
seguono ultimissima consonante
importante lr che gli americani
pronunciano gli inglesi si dimenticano
che gli inglesi la r alla fine di una
vocale e ha quindi interrotto il video
ragazzona immaginatevi di dormire uno di
spreme le mani sulla pancia è quel suono
molto rendete corretto sarebbe quindi
nota fa proprio a farlo è la seconda di
francia non si un po di più perché c'è
dopo perché fa fare perché se tu dici
tipo hanno mai capito che gli entra
rato anche per far paura rapida terza
fiera pressiamo proprio a che in america
non lo so fame tipo fir gli inglesi ciao
dimenticate vera addio è un suono
e adesso entriamo nel vivo della
pronunzia ossia tutte quelle cose che un
sacco di italiani
sbagliano qualche sono alcune delle
regole stabili altri delle cose che
appaiono spesso in elenco mb quando la
frase finisce con mb la b non si dice
mai quindi pettine un agnello la bomba
ponce sono tante sono ponce stupido
arrampicarsi su novembre climb l'ump e
cose così
dimenticatelo mai mai vorrei dire una
cosa con l'abi finale nb file dnb poter
sw una cosa che ho scoperto con game of
thrones che le persone
ok se nella maggior parte dei casi nulla
pronunci da prodotti ha quindi sua sul
web
qui che caso di spada non esiste sud
anche per gli americani soprano dicono
sole la teana netword non ci credo prego
questo trauma fidatevi se non volete
dire all'italiana è sword and sword i
soldati è presente i sword va benissimo
lo stesso e risposta corrispondente ad
una parola bruttissima solo tra
fighissima giocherò o non è answers
orrido hanselmann segrate che sarebbe
le risposte per ansa ora però ansa non
esiste answer restarmi suono di più ok
ma da noi è importantissima wr la w
non si sente altro lifeline inteso come
scrivere ma no adesso era carina ma
anche adesso in avanti
e non c'è dubbio prima che parole quel
bar in pista il loro ok tutto a questo
punto esatto non c'è la doppia marat che
vuol dire senza burrai come suono vuol
dire sia prima la destra che sa scrivere
solo che un e scrittori get e latte
scritto offrite quando c'è la w davanti
alla r non va mai pronuncio per
pronunciata svario rivelazione italiano
se la fase sbagliata è rai o rom non è
pronto
se tu hai deroghe sono ormai fratres il
ps si pronuncia solo psychologist kn
knowledge di ciclone coltello ma il
ginocchio mi plecnik come come la notte
come mai a distinguerne brivido
dell'incomprensione monachus british
rock indie scrocchia niente urla che è
importantissima perché in parole come
list grosso soft la tiratogli non è
caston donelli stand mm software sas un
altro caso nel caso della b di sat sono
uscito non è saputo san suu così come
dubbio è tale non è output e quindi
sotto titoloni su facebook entra invece
quando alla fine è tipo indebito tablet
si legge caro selling
sisley islanda o eisler la la navata
avete presente quelle della sposa che
cammina così che si dice un paio aiuti
nuovo slide sly perché non c'è miseria
vocale esatto non c'è niente perché
matera tipo high flyin high line cioè se
né ma ogni parola sembra dietro alla
ditta diciamo che l'inglese è diverso
l'italiano noi che impariamo a leggere
quello equa questo è un inglese
universale universale poi ci stanno più
o meno in america c'è stato un sacco
differenze ma sono più differenze vocali
che esistono 18 suoni diversi di vocali
però tra inglese cioè tra inglese
britannico inglese americano sono
completamente diversi infatti io lo sto
parlando di vera dell'inglese che ti
insegnerebbero a scuola se magari
facendo buio scusate un'ultimissima cosa
prima di chiudere questo video che ci
tengo tantissimo a dire che sento 2000
ed è l'unica cosa sulla quale faccio
così avete presente contro i pigliate un
vecchi burger
ciò che non sono presente però che c'è
scritto vecchi è neanche lo leggono
neanche lo leggi però in quel caso io
sento un sacco di 20 20 20 mag e
divertente g per favore quella ignoranza
però non è cioè che pensi la pensi più
difficile di quanto sia regime crg
regime di quello vuol dire stare certo
il popò di roba per teoricamente
vistando meti come se tu conosci questo
chiama mag i vecchi flintstones betti
io pensavo fosse margaret può essere
comunque questi qui sono le prime cose
mi sono venuto in mente in realtà ad
elencare spero che possano tornare utili
io come sempre vi dà un appuntamento
alla prossima domenica sono molto
abituato a fare tutorial spiegazioni
spero di migliorare una cosa ma tengo
tantissimo sono i vostri suggerimenti
fatemi sapere se ci sono degli argomenti
in particolari che siano face off che
siano i tempi visto che un sacco di
persone si sbagliano
non lo so fatemi sapere se certi
fondamentale sono analizzati in maniera
completamente diversa presente ci sono
un po di cose che dico perché l'insegna
così a scuola non lo so vabbè fatto
stato contro il sistema scolastico non è
però poracci i professori però una cosa
a cui tengo tantissimo è la vostra
opinione fatemelo sapere qua sotto
savater i consigli sempre rispettando le
regole non rompete la minx ale space ma
soprattutto qual è la terza provato
provateci a mettere un laica in questo
video eventi capite infortuna per sé
troppo chino tipo le catene di
sant'antonio se non lo farete parlerete
vedere essere spedita come red si scisse
a tutti ciao ragazzi grazie mille per il
segno in questo video guida l'esatto
qualche perla della tua vita non va bene
a donare come perle